who's more attractive conservative men
or liberal men I've not really seen an
unattractive conservative man so I'm
pure liberal boyfriend I'm not into the
blue haired painted nails eyeliner
wearing type of guy yeah I mean some
people like you know blue hair and
painted nails but like some people just
have bad taste I mean if you're into
like it thems but I personally I like I
like men yeah that's just a fact that's
true even liberal women if you get them
to be honest will say the same thing
there are studies about this the
conservatives are more attractive than
Libs it is what it is
you know it's just I'm just describing
reality here the reason for it is pretty
clear conservative people generally are
just kind of happy with the way things
are even if they're not physically all
that attractive or anything
conservatives just tend to resign
themselves to the fact of this world and
the libs are pissed off about everything
and they want Revolution wherever they
look and they just throw their fists in
the air and scream no so it's no wonder
that they might have a little bit of a
chip on their shoulder and blue and
their hair